[Musique]
où est né et un regard sur la vie de
whitney houston racontée par sa famille
ses amis et ses plus proches
collaborateurs chacun a sa version de
l'histoire
appuyé par des images d'archivés
inédites et parfois intimiste
[Musique]
cet accès privilégié nous en apprend
beaucoup sur son ascension au sommet des
palmarès
il y a des moments savoureux comme sa
majestueuse prestation au super bowl
on apprend qu'elle avait à peine répété
[Musique]
aussi kevin place nous revient sur le
film le garde du corps du leinster
mais ce documentaire montre qu'en
coulisse la vie de whitney houston
n'avait rien d'un conte de fées
le réalisateur kevin mcdonald lève le
voile sur la consommation de cocaïne de
la chanteuse at elle perdu le contrôle
lors de cette entrevue avec ton sérieux
de la chaîne nbc qu'est-ce-qui
confidences à l'appui le film aborde
aussi la relation tumultueuse de whitney
houston avec son mari le chanteur bobby
brown
il est aussi question des problèmes
financiers de la chanteuse et de son
père qui intentent une poursuite de 100
millions de dollars contre elle swiss
tennis de records la grande révélation
de ce film est sans aucun doute cette
allégations voulant que whitney houston
est été agressé sexuellement un très
jeune âge par une cousine de près de
vingt ans son aîné
aucune accusation n'a été portée mais
des proches affirment qu'il s'agissait
d'un secret lourd à porter dans ce
documentaire certaines questions
importantes n'ont pas été posées par
exemple pourquoi personne n'a vraiment
réussi à protéger whitney houston du
d'allemagne ici les primes radio qu'un
rameau rien